Hallo ihr Lieben! Heute gibt es einen sehr, sehr stark angefragten Kuchen: Wir machen den Red Velvet Cake!
Das ist der rote Samtkuchen aus Amerika!
Und eigentlich gibt's den schon seit über 100 Jahren und entstanden ist er durch eine chemische Reaktion
denn das darin enthaltene Backkakao zusammen mit etwas säurehaltigem - meistens ist das dann Buttermilch oder Essig - reagiert so, dass der Kuchen rötlich aussieht!
Ich gebe in meinem Rezept - und das ist glaube ich heutzutage auch ganz normal - ich gebe noch rote Lebensmittelfarbe mit dazu.
Das ist natürlich euch überlassen aber sonst wäre mir einfach die Farbe nicht knallig genug.
Und letztens kam übrigens eine Frage - Ich muss es nochmal ganz kurz erzählen! -
über Instagram ob denn der Red Velvet Cake nicht einfach nur ein Rührkuchen ist mit ein bisschen roter Lebensmittelfarbe.
Aber es ist wirklich so, dass die Textur ganz anders ist durch die darin enthaltenen Zutaten,
dass es wirklich so samtig-schokoladig und vanillig schmeckt.
Daher müsst ihr dem unbedingt mal eine Chance geben und das Ganze mal ausprobieren!
Ihr findet alle ganz genauen Mengenangaben unten in der...?
[Hamza]...Infobox!
[Kiki] Infobox!
[Hamza] Und dürfen wir mal was sagen kurz?
[Kiki] Ja bitte?
[Hamza] Du siehst heute echt bezaubernd aus!
[Kiki] Och!
[Hamza] *lacht*
[Kiki] Och Maaann!
[Kiki] Nein, mach das weg!
[Hamza] Ich bring dich aus der Fassung jetzt!
[Kiki] Ich hab mir heut extra was rotes angezogen!
[Hamza] Komm alles gut, mach mal weiter!
[Kiki] So, weiter geht's! Also!
Die Butter muss zimmerwarm sein, das ist super, super wichtig!
Generell rate ich euch, dass alle Zutaten bei diesem Rezept auf Zimmertemperatur sind,
zumindest was die Zutaten für den Teig angeht.
So und da gebe ich jetzt direkt noch Butter mit dazu und eine Prise Salz
und schlage das ungefähr 3min lang.
Ihr dürft aber auch gerne euer Handrührgerät benutzen wenn ihr jetzt keine Küchenmaschine da habt.
Aaah! Verdammt!
[Hamza] Du hast 2 Eier reingehauen!
Ihr solltet jetzt nacheinander bei geringer Geschwindigkeit die Eier unterrühren.
Jetzt sind mir 2 auf einmal reingeploppt, ist auch nicht schlimm!
Als nächstes gebt ihr das neutrale Öl dazu.
Da dürft ihr Rapsöl nehmen, Sonnenblumenöl oder Distelöl, je nachdem, was ihr da habt.
Hauptsache es schmeckt jetzt nicht so extrem, jetzt würde z.B. kein Olivenöl da reinpassen.
Aber wie immer schreibe ich euch alle Infos, Tipps und Tricks in die Videobeschreibung!
So, an trockenen Zutaten habe - *Schüssel klirrt*
*lacht*
So, an trockenen Zutaten habe ich jetzt Mehl Typ 405, ganz normales Weizenmehl,
Backkakao, - Das ist stark entölter Kakao, also keinen Trinkkakao benutzen! - und Natron.
Statt Backpulver benutzen wir in diesem Rezept Natron.
Und wichtig ist, dass wir vorher alles gründlich miteinander sieben.
Beziehungsweise Natron muss eigentlich nicht gesiebt werden, der ist sehr fein.
Aber im Mehl und im Backkakao könnten Klümpchen drin sein und das wäre dann nicht sehr förderlich!
So, jetzt gebe ich vorab noch - ganz, ganz wichtig! - Apfelessig und Vanilleextrakt mit dazu.
Und dann könnt ihr auch schon abwechselnd Buttermilch - Die ist sehr wichtig in diesem Rezept! -
Buttermilch abwechselnd mit den eben vermischten trockenen Zutaten in den Teig geben.
Wichtig ist, dass das wirklich immer abwechselnd passiert damit der Teig nicht auf einmal anfängt, zu klumpen.
Und ich rate euch auch, dass die Buttermilch schön auf Zimmertemperatur ist damit sie sich besser mit dem Teig verbindet.
Dem Teig habe ich jetzt noch rote Lebensmittelgelfarbe zugefügt und guckt:
Das sieht schon richtig gut aus und nach dem Backen wird das nochmal richtig, richtig rot!
So und bevor ich jetzt meinen Teig in meine Tortenringe einfülle,
zeige ich euch kurz, wie ihr mit Tortenringen ohne Boden backen könnt.
Da kommt nämlich auch ganz oft die Nachfrage. Vor allem weil dieser Teig ein bisschen flüssiger ist.
Also ein bisschen flüssiger, ihr dürft ihn euch nicht komplett flüssig vorstellen!
Ich habe jetzt 2 Tortenringe und das ist wirklich typischerweise so, dass man
Red Velvet Cakes auch jeden Boden einzeln backt.
Das heißt ich möchte jetzt 2 Böden haben und nehme mir deshalb 2 Tortenringe.
Wenn ihr mögt, verwendet auch gerne eine Springform. Beachtet bitte nur bei meinem Rezept die Größe.
Ich habe jetzt hier einen Durchmesser von 20cm eingestellt.
Und jetzt nehme mir einen Backpapierzuschnitt
und gehe da quasi immer wieder mit meinem Backpapier an den Rand meines Tortenrings in Dreiecksbewegungen.
Ich zeige euch das am besten mal.
Und dabei dreht ihr quasi den Tortenring, das ist für mich immer die einfachste Methode.
So!
So, und wenn ihr dann angekommen seid, knickt ihr das einfach rein und fertig!
Und jetzt könnt ihr darin ganz normal backen und wenn euch was ausläuft, dann wirklich nur minimal! Das nimmt man dann aber auch in Kauf.
Die Böden brauchen bei 180° C Ober- und Unterhitze im vorgeheizten Backofen ½h.
Also nach 30min sind sie gar und danach könnt ihr sie zugedeckt einmal vollständig auskühlen lassen.
Ich widme mich in der Zwischenzeit der Creme und im Original Red Velvet Cake benutzt man eine Buttercreme.
Da ist ein großer Anteil an Butter und ein großer Anteil an Frischkäse.
Jetzt habe ich mir überlegt: Weil immer, wenn ich Buttercreme mach -
Also ich kriege sie auch wirklich lecker hin! Ihr könnt euch gerne meine Rosentorte z.B. ansehen.
Ich mag Buttercreme wenn man sie richtig macht.
Aber viele von euch haben geschrieben: "Kiki ich mag keine Buttercreme!"
Und deshalb habe ich mir bei diesem Rezept überlegt ich mache eine Creme aus leckeren Zutaten wie
Frischkäse, Mascarpone, Sahne, Vanille und ein bisschen Puderzucker.
Ich denke das ist eine schöne Alternative und ich möchte ja auch, dass es schmeckt!
[Hamza] Finde ich auch, ja!
[Kiki] Genau!
Ich starte jetzt direkt mit der Küchenmaschine und ich mach's mir immer ganz, ganz einfach!
Ich glaube, das kennt ihr auch schon von mir. Ich nehme jetzt alle Zutaten, die ganz kalt aus dem Kühlschrank kommen
in die Schüssel der Küchenmaschine mit Schneebesenaufsatz.
Auch die beiden sind ebenfalls kalt, also ihr dürft sie nicht warm abspülen oder so.
Und da gebe ich jetzt alle Zutaten hinein und dann fange ich an, das langsam zu verrühren
und dann auf voller Geschwindigkeit so zu schlagen, dass die Sahne in der Creme steif wird
und somit auch die ganze Creme fertig wird. Das dauert vielleicht maximal 1min und dann ist es auch schon fertig.
1:11min, das ist die schnellste Creme der Welt!
Und einen Teil davon fülle ich mir jetzt schon mal in meinen Spritzbeutel für die spätere Deko.
Übrigens Leute: Wenn ihr kaum bis gar keine Lebensmittelfarbe verwendet,
dann ist das eher so ein dunkelbrauner Kuchen.
Also haut ruhig viel Lebensmittelfarbe rein!
So, jetzt habe ich mir einen kleinen Teil für die Deko später aufgehoben
und in meinen Spritzbeutel mit Sterntülle vorne dran schon mal reingegeben.
Und was ich auch schon gemacht hab ist meine Böden vom Tortenring zu lösen und sie gerade abzuschneiden.
Ich hatte schon ein bisschen Angst, dass ich keinen Verschnitt habe weil sie fast perfekt gerade gebacken sind
aber wir brauchen ein bisschen Verschnitt für die Dekoration später.
Kommt gleich zum Einsatz, dürft ihr auch schon ein bisschen naschen.
Aber nicht alles damit wir noch ein bisschen haben!
Und jetzt habe ich mir den ersten Boden schon mal auf eine hübsche Servierplatte gelegt.
Und das Einzige, das wir jetzt noch machen müssen, ist die restliche Creme zu nehmen
und die Torte zu füllen und anschließend auch von außen zu verstreichen.
Ich persönliche mache es so, dass ich gleich außen erstmal nur eine dünne Schicht verstreiche zur Krümelbindung
und lasse ich's ganz kurz einmal auskühlen im Kühlschrank für 10-15min
und dann kommt noch eine 2. Schicht dazu damit's richtig schön glatt wird.
Aber Leute: Ihr müsst euch auch nicht so, so, so viel Mühe geben denn später kommen eh noch die Kuchenkrümel außenherum.
Das wird am Ende eine richtig, richtig hübsche Torte.
Um die Kanten jetzt gerade verstreichen zu können, einfach mit der Winkelpalette richtig schön senkrecht die Creme nach innen streichen.
So, jetzt werden wir die Torte noch dekorieren und dann ist sie auch schon fertig.
Und ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt, mir schlägt das Herz grad ein bisschen höher
Ich war auch noch nie so aufgeregt, eine Torte in Stücke einzuteilen!
Aber ihr folgt mir ja nicht alle auf Instagram!
Ihr könnt das jetzt gerne nachholen aber für alle, die's halt noch nicht bekommen haben:
Eine Weltneuheit gibt's von mir und zwar haben wir hieran in den letzten Monaten gearbeitet!
Das ist ein Torteneinteiler aus Edelstahl, spülmaschinengeeignet, natürlich rostfrei
und 100% hergestellt in Deutschland.
Und der Unterschied ist halt erstens er ist nicht aus Kunststoff so wie herkömmliche Torteneinteiler.
[Hamza] Der Unterschied ist, dass das aussieht wie 'ne Radkappe und das nicht!
Das soll aussehen wie eine Radkappe habt ihr ganz viel auf Instagram geschrieben!
Aber viele sind halt auch dankbar, dass es solche Alternativen gibt
denn das hier, das hat mich so genervt, da bin ich ganz ehrlich! Das nimmt so viel Platz in meinem Schrank weg.
Und sind wir mal ehrlich: Wir haben alle keinen Platz in unseren Schränken!
Selbst ich, obwohl ich eine große Küche hab! Ich hab keen Platz!
Und das verstaue ich hier in meiner Schublade und weg ist es!
So und das habe ich als 12-er und als 14-er Variante.
Diese Torte werde ich jetzt in 12 Stücke einteilen.
Sie ist zwar relativ hoch aber ich finde 12 sind da ganz schön angemessen.
Und jetzt gehe ich hier einfach rein...
So...
Und hoch...
So, und fertig! Und jetzt kann ich einfach dekorieren.
Ich hab ja hier meinen Spritzbeutel
und jetzt mache ich da so schöne Röschen bzw. ja, so..
Ja, das sieht ganz schick aus!
Genau, hier könnt ihr dann die Stücke entlang schneiden. Und jetzt nehmt ihr euch die Kuchenreste,
zerbröselt die mit den Fingern und ich geb sie jetzt hier erstmal an den Rand der Torte.
Das ist echt eine der hübschesten Torten, die ich je gemacht habe, ich freue mich auch riesig auf den Anschnitt!
Und wenn ihr den Taste Test und ehrliche Kritik von Hamza nicht verpassen möchtet,
Dann bleibt auf jeden Fall bis zum Schluss dran und schreibt mir in die Kommentare..
Irgendeinen Kommentar! Ich freue mich einfach immer, von euch zu lesen.
Und dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem nächsten Video! Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] Leute von heute! Boah, das war so uncool!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Also, es geht los! Taste Test Red Velvet Cake!
[Hamza] Weißt du eigentlich, was Velvet heißt?
[Kiki] Samt!
[Hamza] Uuuh, Samt!
[Hamza] So, wir haben hier eine schöne, leckere Creme, dann einen roten Boden,
[Hamza] Creme, roten Boden. So, probieren wir mal!
[Hamza] Soll ich jetzt beides mitnehmen? Beide Cremes oder nur eine Creme?
[Kiki] Also Hauptsache du probierst vom Boden und von der Creme. Wie viel ist egal!
[Kiki] Ich weiß, du wirst den lieben. Das ist genau was für dich!
[Hamza] Ich bin gespannt!
[Hamza] Mmmmh!
[Kiki] Mega, ne?
[Hamza] Boah der Boden, ne? Mmmh!
[Hamza] Der Boden ist einfach nur saftig!
[Hamza] Ich will nicht schmatzen und reden aber der ist heftig, Kiki!
[Kiki] Oder?!
[Hamza] Boah, heftig!
[Hamza] Also ich finde..
[Kiki] Der ist einfach nur saftig und lecker!
[Hamza] ..der Boden stiehlt voll der Creme die Show! Volle Kanne!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Der ist..der Boden ist heftig!
[Hamza] Also ich bin ehrlich zu dir: Ich hab gedacht das wird einfach ein roter Boden!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Aber vom Geschmack her - Ich weiß jetzt nicht, was du da gemacht hast, ich hab das nicht beobachtet!
[Kiki] *lacht*
[Hamza] Aber vom Geschmack her: heftig!
[Hamza] Der ist so weich, so geil! Ehrlich!
[Kiki] Krass, ne? Du könntest den Boden auch einfach alleine essen, oder?
[Hamza] M-hm, mega!
[Hamza] Ey Kiki du siehst, ne? Ich ess' die ganze Zeit!
[Hamza] Leute, kein Spaß: Der ist einfach von ner andren Liga! Das ist ein Champions League Kuchen!
[Kiki] Krass!
[Hamza] Ehrlich!
[Hamza] Guck mal, ich sag dir ganz ehrlich was: Ich habe nur einige Lieblingskuchen aber der gehört jetzt dazu!
[Kiki] Krass! Heftig!
[Hamza] Der ist heftig! Ich schwör's euch Leute, ich schwöre ich übertreibe nicht!
[Hamza] Leg, geh, hol mir Feuer! Hier, Feuer, hier!
[Kiki] *lacht* Nein!
[Hamza] Ah, heiß!
[Hamza] Egal, ich wollt's euch nur zeigen!
[Kiki] Nicht, dass das Video jetzt gelb wird wegen dir!
[Hamza] Ist egal! Ich wollte euch nur zeigen: Ey, das schmeckt heftig!
[Hamza] Ich wollte meine Hand ins Feuer legen aber das reicht!
[Kiki] Krass, ja! Das macht aber auch die ganzen..hier, da ist Buttermilch drin in Verbindung mit Natron..
[Hamza] Wer das probiert und sagt: "Hamza, es schmeckt nicht!", der lügt!
[Hamza] Ohne Witz, das schmeckt heftig Kiki!
[Hamza] Du weißt, ich raste nicht oft aus bei Kuchen oder sonstwas! Aber das ist...
[Kiki] Ja, das stimmt.
[Kiki] Krass!
[Hamza] Das letzt Mal, das ich so ausgerastet bin, war der San Sebastian Cheesecake!
[Hamza] Das heißt schon was! Okay!
[Kiki] Ja, krass!
[Kiki] Danke für dein Feedback!
[Hamza] Ich will nicht mehr lachen weil wenn ich lache, krieg ich Segelohren!
[Hamza] Also Leute, unbedingt nachmachen weil..
[Hamza] ...also meine Nase ist zwar groß aber bei Pinocchio wird die noch größer wenn er lügt aber bei mir - ich lüge nicht!
*beide lachen*
[Kiki] Okay! Dankeschön für deine Bewertung!
[Hamza] Leute ernsthaft, nachmachen!
[Hamza] Hammer, hammer!
[Kiki] Okay, Danke!
*Siri: Das übersteigt möglicherweise meine Fähigkeiten.*
[Hamza] Ey sogar Siri weiß nicht, was sie sagen soll!
[Hamza] Woher kommt der Kuchen eigentlich?
[Kiki] Aus Amerika, Anfang 20. Jahrhundert!
[Kiki] Und bekannt wurde er durch die Serie Sex and the City. Dort wurde er in der-
[Hamza] And the City!
[Kiki] In der Magnolia Bakery haben die den dort bestellt. Den gibt's auch heute noch in der Magnolia Bakery.
[Kiki] Auch als Cupcakes. Ich kann den auch gerne mal als Cupcakes machen!
[Hamza] Ganz ehrlich ey: Normalerweise muss man einen Laden aufmachen nur mit sowas!
[Kiki] Ja!
[Hamza] Leute, nachmachen! Peace and out! Abonnieren und liken nicht vergessen.